good evening ladies and gentlemen well
it appears spring has sprung here in New
York City and is so nice to see so many
of you out tonight as a reminder we have
just two more forums coming up our next
one on April 24th guns and money
tracking underground funds in a
borderless economy we welcome you back
on april twenty fourth for that but
tonight we have an interesting very
interesting topic immigration backlash
labor migration in crisis and in just a
minute i will have our moderator
introduce tonight's guest talents i'm
also pleased to let you know that
foreign policy magazine has given us a
gift you may all pick up your copy if
you haven't already up at the
registration desk there is an
interesting interview inside fine Anna
remembers endorsed my sermon was on our
panel tonight so I hope you've built you
to cook up to copy I take it home and
read it we're also very pleased tonight
to have with us and a regular guest at
the Reuters form of data center so is
now head of news here in New York City
first and it's always a pleasure to have
anyone for lawyers here especially since
they sponsor the lawyers for so welcome
to all and I'm now going to introduce
Steve shippers will be handling the rest
of tonight's program don't let Steve's
British accent we knew he was actually
born in New York City and raised in New
Jersey but he's become a British file he
lives alone in London see now he was
here in New York I i had the pleasure of
knowing him when he spent a year as a
knight Badgett following class of 93 94
he now runs to the BBC's online website
and it has been a business journalist
for ever I'm not going to take up as you
can read his file of course on the back
of
flyer something but not going to pick up
any more of his time I want to let Steve
introduce the rest of our speakers
and thank you all for coming I just like
to say a few words as well that is very
important topic we're discussing tonight
globalization I think it's perhaps even
more important in post-september 11th
World and immigration and migration of
some of the most important issues facing
us in a globalized world just to remind
you some of the facts there according to
the UN more than 100 million migrants
are immigrants every year who move
around the world the u.s. receives the
largest number of immigrants of any
country and nearly 30 million new a
group thing we're going to move the
United States since 1970 provoking a
lively debate even before the events
will be discussing tonight the
immigration nationalization service
which is the body charged with
regulating the flow in which faces a
very difficult task as we know it's
currently its restructuring is being
discussed in Congress there's some 500
million entries every year the United
States six million green card
applications 100,000 refugees admitted 1
million criminal investigations and
170,000 deportations that's just
something about the scale of the task
facing the Immigration Service and Sonny
what to do in a world where we now
perhaps are feeling that more insecure
than ever in feelings task of
immigration is harder than ever finding
the border between providing security
the country and providing that okin
approach to immigration which of course
the United States was founded on and
luckily we have a very distinguished
group of panelists to discuss these
issues will be joined tonight by Randy
Hmoob there's a civil rights lawyer from
San Diego mr. Hamid was thrown into the
issues relating to succumb
11th when he took on three clients who
were young arab muslim men arrested as
material witnesses in a post-911
dragonette one of them is still in
detention one is free on bail and one
has been found to have no connection to
any of the events and has been released
since his involvement he's been a very
outspoken advocate and has raised the
questions really that we need to
consider about civil rights implications
of 911 for how we will regulate
immigration in the future David
Schlesinger who we was already been
introduced is the executive vice
president of Reuters for the Americas
which means he covers both North and
South America leading a team of 650
journalists cameramen and photographers
mr. Schlesinger started his career
actually covering China and Far East his
first job was a high school teacher in
Hong Kong before beginning of
distinguished career as a journalist and
he had 13 years in the far east before
moving on back the United States dr. Zia
ashley is president of the arab-american
discrimination committee he assumed the
presidency just one month before the
events of September 11 and his face the
difficult task since then in trying to
ensure that the civil rights of our
Americans are not negatively affected by
the fears and concerns that followed the
terrible events of that month he was
born in Jerusalem and is a graduate of
the American University of the medical
school but he's been a practicing doctor
in the United States for many years and
was medical director and chairman of the
board at christian county medical clinic
near springfield illinois until he
retired last year and finally
we're very pleased to be joined by Doris
moistness who was the Commissioner of
immigration and naturalization in the
Clinton administration miss Meisner was
in charge a very important series of the
forms of that very including changes to
the asylum system new strategies to
manage the borders of the United States
particularly with Mexico and Canada in
the context of the NAFTA agreement and
managing humanitarian and migration
crisis that occurred during her period
auditors she has a long the superior
department justice but was also in
between influential and founding the
carnegie endowment program on
international migration which is now
become its own think tank and since
retiring from the hostess commissioner
she's returned to the carnegie endowment
where she is now senior associate so
very pleased to welcome the panelists
will have short statements from each of
them in order and then we'll open the
floor to questions which they'll be able
to respond hopefully we'll have about an
hour for questions but first I'd like to
hear from mr. Holman
I'd like to begin matters widely with
the joke but I'm not in a very joking
mood I arrived in New York a couple of
days ago and yesterday you might have
read in the newspapers that an attorney
who's representing her and has
represented in the past a gentleman
named sheikh abdul-rahman has been
indicted by the govern states or
allegedly passing terrorist messages
from her client at prison to alleged
henchmen on the outside I consider that
to be an abject attack by attorney
general Ashcroft against the defense
counsel across United States against any
lawyers intending to defend any any
suspected terrorists or detainee who
might be at Middle East persuasion it
will have a chilling effect by
definition i looked at the charges i
haven't read the indictment i noticed
that they relate to incidents that
allegedly occurred in october of 1999
april may and june of two thousand wife
took the attorney general's office so
long to charge this lawyer with these
alleged egregious violations i do not
actually know that I suspect there's
more spin I've been involved in the
maelstrom of September 11 since as all
of you September 11th although my roles
then a little different I found myself
representing three young Arab men who
were arrested in San Diego as material
witnesses so there will be no doubt
about their situation none I repeat none
has been alleged to have had any ties
with any of the planning for the events
of September 11 for al-qaeda or any
terrorist connections whatsoever the two
basically made under charges by the
federal government one of them faces
charges that he allegedly lied about an
immigration asylum application in May of
2000 the other mr. Amidala was here in
New York he testified as a material
witness for a grand jury he became
confused about the testimony regarding
the identity of a person and also the
shift of a document even though he
rehabilitated his testimony he's been
charged with two counts of line of the
grand jury none of which applies to any
terrorist links or terrorist-related
activities the point is they're Arab men
there there under these charges and
cloud or stigma because of their
ethnicity and because of the terrible
events of September 11th one of the
questions I think today is has there
been a change in immigration policy
sense of Kimber 11th yes without any
question there's a new paradigm I am an
example of it I represent the best and
the worst of immigration policy United
States in the 1920s my grandparents came
here no skills they brought a new
culture a new religion new foods and
something very important to this country
at that time a work ethic two
generations later and they weren't
educated either by the way but they
brought work and they brought loyalty to
the country and industry and they
brought potential families I'm a product
of that okay two generations later I'm
an attorney with UCLA law school
respected member of society and a
contributing member of society I think
however today in today's environment my
grandparents would not be welcome to
this country it would be young people
they would be discouraged from
immigrating the is in September 11th has
become a weapon of oppression rather
than a weapon rather than a facilitator
of immigration it's an instrument of
immigration with an e secret detentions
characterized I&S arrests we have
several hundred arab men today who are
in custody who we don't know who they
are where they are
their welfare we don't know if they have
attorneys we don't know what their
future holds for them by unique to the
United States government we have secret
I&S hearings which is a violation of due
process of law and a courageous judge
has disrupted that decision within the
past three days I believe to the effect
that olive oil the attorney general's
office and judge copies ordered that I
NS proceedings relating to basically
Arabs and Muslims and Middle East be
sealed that's not right they have to
have these trials on public where they
can be seen we have the attorney
general's office demanding in to
interview legitimate immigrating or
visiting Arabs and Muslims who have
coming to the country since january two
thousand first group six thousand last
group approximately 3,000 they have
these interviews and it happens they
come forward to interview on occasion
without counsel i have a client would
call me just this week about that he
gave information to the FBI and then an
IAS officer walked in such as some
problem to resend the arrest of them
when they arrest air to the Middle East
now and there's a list of 25 countries
are basically Moslem or Islamic
countries they are held without bond no
bail holes because of their ethnicity
there is a new paradigm anti-immigrant
the country is anti-immigrant it
xenophobic relative to my ethnic group
Arabs Muslims Middle East whether it
will spread like a cancer to other
ethnic groups I can't guarantee that it
will but I suspect it will I suspect
that if it weren't for the fact that of
the 8 million or so undocumented people
are in this country and a lion's share
them or Hispanic and there's a large
Hispanic vote that neither the political
parties would be schmoozing hispanic
vote and talking about amnesty for
hispanic and we're Mexican immigrants
because they would just basically want
to get rid of them to you can take a
look at the best sellers list here in
New York take a look at the American
jihad I hit piece against Islam by a
historic Israel apologist named Steve
Emerson news
fame before September 11th was stating
on nationwide TV a few minutes after the
terrible bombing in the federal building
in oklahoma city that arab terrorists
were responsible for that highness act
we have Pat Buchanan's book the decline
of Western civilization he attributed to
immigration so country of immigrants is
no longer a country of immigrants it's a
country of people who don't like
immigration one of the catchwords
recently i think has been globalization
what does it mean to me it means
opportunities for fellows like George
Soros to exploit global currencies and
to destroy local economies to me it
means opportunities to create sweatshops
in Bangladesh and other places so Mikey
you know so there's other companies can
put their stripes on the shoes and so on
here to me it means environmental
destruction because environmental laws
in this country might be too difficult
to contend with in this quote global
postcode economy but also to me it also
means it's an anti-immigrant concept no
longer do you need immigrants to come to
your country to benefit your country
because it's cyberspace the global
communications network you can exploit
insight to so the immigrants don't have
to come here anymore so we can take
advantage of the labor and apply their
ethic their work ethic here we can do it
abroad not evolve with them I think
that's happening but however if we
haven't had some skills shortage then
we'll be glad to drain off the skills
people by giving certain in a work visas
for people with special skills to take
them out of those third world countries
where we exploit the local population by
having training them enough to perform
you know jobs it would be higher pain
here but if you know what
over there so I think it some people may
call it a clash of civilizations I call
it a clash of wrote economics it's a
very capitalist driven cynical if you
will society in which we find ourselves
after the Cold War's demise there's no
reason for anybody to prove him
rehearsal better than the other fellow
or more moral than the other fellow as
it was the bifurcation between between
East and West after a post-war in the
postwar world now it's the most
basically economic efficient and
possibly the richest fellow who's the
one that counts the most so I think
globalization in itself breathes
anti-immigrant feelings in the developed
countries especially this one now sep
tember liveth has been a catalyst I
think for for a whole movement towards
reduction and elimination of immigration
and the conversion of what we call
immigration to immigration with an E and
it's a very bottle some time to me and
my ethnic group and I think we would be
categorized as the first of several to
follow and I think it is food for
thought I think the historic benefits of
immigration that made this country Drake
blob my grandparents to come here and
make this country great are are now
occluded and clouded over by the
concepts well we don't need unskilled
people anymore we just need the skill
people to come here we just need small
numbers of them to make up for own labor
pool as soon as we do in training of
scientists and computer technology
people then we won't need them anymore
either so we don't need immigrants so
it's a global economy I think it's going
to be an economy of discrete exploited
local people's until such time as there
is a single market in a single currency
worldwide which we don't have and I
think immigration is going to be the
early victim of that and sep tember
eleventh was married
merely a catalyst that happen to fall on
my people's shoulders tragically and I
don't see any light at the end of our
tunnel of this particular time thank you
thank you as the journalist thought that
panel my role is to take somewhat more
of an overview of the situation but it's
certainly difficult to take a more
emotional overview after following such
a heartfelt let's speak by the planet
earth would i but even as a journalist
exposed to take the more objective view
I find that I am very much part of this
story I work for waters the company
which make this living as part of the
globalization trade we make our living
trying to explain one culture to another
we make our living by having journalists
in every country in the world trying to
tell the stories objectively but often
struggling by being part of the story
ourselves by being in areas which show
are full of emotion full of tumult full
of problems I myself and the first
person in my family to be born in the
United States my wife was the first
person in her family to be born in Hong
Kong and now she's a naturalized
American so like many of us I'm part of
the immigration story we are a nation of
immigrants in the United States ten
percent of the population is its foreign
born twenty percent of the population is
a foreign stop meaning that they're
either foreign-born or have at least one
foreign parents one out of five so when
we talk about immigration backlash I
think we have to be very careful that
we're not just taking a slice of time
right around the verifica vents of
September 11 I think it's very important
so we look at the big picture the
picture where the proportion of
immigrants in foreign-born people in the
United States has doubled from
four-point-seven percent in 1972 that
10.4 percent that I just talked about
and when you have twenty percent of the
population now of foreign stock and if
you have the fact that people of foreign
stuff actually that those family sizes
are growing faster then pretty soon the
you cannot have an immigration backlash
because of the proportion of people in
the country who have a personal stake in
the immigration question I think we have
to be very careful to separate out
questions of discrimination questions of
anti-arab prejudice which there
certainly are right now we have to
separate those particular questions from
the broader question of is there a
problem with immigration is there a
problem with the United States's feeling
towards other countries and welcoming
people from other countries I think when
you look globally what we what you have
you have to focus on is the fear of the
other fear the unassimilated the fear
that comes from economic hard times and
from fear of crime and I think you have
to separate those you have to isolate
what are the factors that cause people
to have either an anti-air feeling or to
pass anti-immigration laws or to have by
other factors win elections or a
political polls that then no I can be
interpreted as just a backlash against
immigration writ large I think you run
into trouble when you try to put
everything into you into one pot what we
have after the events of 911 is very
much a lashing out a feeling of
powerlessness so what can we do we can
we can attack an ethnic group what can
we do we can attack a government agency
which through certainly faults of its
own and so I've been a magnet for for
attack but these these lashing out this
momentary lashing out in the wake of 911
I think you have to put into a broader
historical context which is growing
immigration of the United States and the
growing globalization worldwide which i
think is going to lead to not an
immigration backlash but it's going to
make immigration in fact we're like very
natural thing
and as time goes on as the proportion of
people who have a personal stake both
here in the United States and worldwide
have much more of a personal stake in
the free flow of people just as they
have a stake in the free flow of money
the free flow of ideas the free full of
goods I think what you will have is not
an immigrations backlash but you'll have
immigration assimilated much more into
the fabric of the world thank you lastly
thank you very much I guess I'm the only
two immigrant there on this panel and
I'm going to read out of a prepared text
perhaps of course I'm an immigrant one
message for you today is that through a
series of new policies and practices
introduces the appalling terrorist
attacks of sep tember 11 our government
has in subtle but insidious ways we
reintroduce an element of ethnic
discrimination into our immigration
policies and law enforcement practices I
will demonstrate this to you by placing
a thread through several new practices
each of which would be rationalized or
tolerated as a liberation when taken on
its own but which taken together amount
to a pattern of ethnic discrimination
that should be troubling to all
Americans everyone agrees that Homeland
Security is an important priority in the
wake of these despicable attacks and
everyone also agrees that you attention
should be given to reforming the
processes by which visitors to the
United States come into and stay in our
country our point is that these
practices need to be colorblind so to
speak and they must not be allowed to
reflect a pattern of official bias I
have in mind particularly for practices
that reveal a consistent pattern of salt
that amounts to systematize
discrimination the
these is the secret detention in
facilities around the country of
hundreds of men mostly Arabs or Muslims
these are not accused or even suspected
of involvement in any form of terrorism
or having knowledge of any form of
terrorism they are simply or Muslim men
picked up since nine eleven who are in
some way including extremely trivial
ways out of stats the policy of the I NS
as expressed in this detention synth now
to be that if you are an Arab or a
Muslim who is out of status in any way
whatsoever you will be detained
indefinitely without bond and deported
other non-citizens with similar
technical visa problems are not be
incarcerated in this Rako nyan manner or
departed for trivial reasons the case of
the Pakistani man and Salma moon whose
unjust deportation was it subject of a
blistering editorial attack in the
Washington Post illustrates how harsh
and unfair these deportations can be
moreover we have no way of knowing how
many people are being helped under such
circumstances since the government will
not release this basic information and
refuses to comply with FOIA requests
made by NBC ACLU and 20 other
organizations one thing we do know
however is that these men would not be
in jail if they had a different
ethnicity or religious affiliation
secondly outside that investigation in
thousands of young men again mostly
Arabs based on their age national origin
gender and time of entry into the United
States the government initially sought
the interview of 5,000 people based on
these broad categories and now seeks to
investigate an additional three thousand
more we strongly feel that this amounts
a form of racial profiling since the
criteria are so crude and broad-based we
know that the government
is using these so called voluntary
interviews to find and arrest additional
people who are out of stats the
information gathered in this manner is
being collected in a nation data base
which suggests that the whole point of
the exercise is to collect and maintain
detail dossiers on people of certain
description to whip young Arab men no
comparable effort to investigate any
similar group of non-citizens in the
United States exists as far as we know
thirdly I will point out that the
prioritization of finding the presumed
Middle Easterners among the three
hundred and fifteen thousand or so
absconders persons ordered deported but
who remain in the country again
demonstrates a clear bias they move to
add the list of absconders the National
Crime Database is part of a broader
effort to bring regular police and law
enforcement into immigration law
enforcement activities that have
heretofore been the provenance of the i
ns but by adding six thousand presume
Middle Easterners and others among the
three hundred thousand afterwards the
government is placing a priority on
removing a group of absconders based on
their ethnicity finally I would say that
the new visa screening procedures were
males aged 16 to 45 from Arab states and
other Muslim nations will have to answer
a special questionnaire in addition to
the one required of all applicants and
wait an extra 20 days is a clear policy
of discrimination I would argue that by
connecting the dots so to speak by
examining these policies together the
detentions the investigations absconders
and the new visa screening rules a
pattern of coherent systematic
discrimination begins to emerge
essentially we have recast our
immigration system to involve two
completely different standards one for
young arab males and another for
everyone else the thinking behind these
is clear and consistent young men males
are now young arab males are now
considered by our government to be by
definition suspicious potentially
dangerous and of interest to the herpes
this idea moreover cannot be contained
to these policies in the long run if we
allow it to take root in our policies if
they well authorize similar forms of
discrimination in many other instances
this is particularly disturbing given
new powers for state local and federal
law enforcement or to enforce
immigration laws it is our understanding
that the Justice Department is about to
release a legal opinion that will say
that states and localities have the
inherent authority to reinforce
immigration laws this will presumably
clear the way for local police agencies
that wish to do so to arrest and detain
persons both based on suspected
immigration law violations apparently
without undergoing trading in
immigration laws and policies we're
already receiving reports of university
students being a stop on campus by
campus police and subjected to
questioning about their visa status
there is every danger that this new
approach is not handed with the greatest
possible care will bring us one step
closer to becoming a police state or
developed into a witch-hunt against
persons who appear to be of arab
ethnicity moreover any time the
government itself is seen to be acting
in an inherently discriminatory fashion
it tends to authorize others in society
to discriminate as well and reinforce
prejudices that produce various forms of
discrimination and even hate crimes some
argue that altering the immigration
system to include anti-arab
discriminatory practices is warranted by
September attacks I would certainly
argue it is not acting in the name of
national security
he based on such crude stereotypes
painting millions of people's with a
broad brush of suspicion based on flimsy
profile of each gender and ethnicity
will not enhance our security it will
diverge scarce law enforcement and
security resources away from truly
effective measures that deal with
actually existing security threats
towards thousands of people about whom
there is no rational reason to be
concerned I'm glad to say that are many
in law enforcement and counterterrorism
field who agree with us on this point as
Vincent can estranha the former head of
counterterrorism for the CIA has pointed
out ethnicity is a false lead in other
words it does not tell you anything
useful about whether or not someone can
reasonably be regarded as suspicious we
are gratified but not surprised that
opposition to the dragnet investigation
was widespread in the law-enforcement
community to the extent that a number of
local police chiefs simply refuse to
allow their officers to be involved in a
project that struck many of them as
indefensible not what the police should
be doing and in some places even in
possible violation of local law or
consent decrees the idea that
introducing discriminatory practices
into our immigration system will bring
us greater security simply does not
stand up to scrutiny although it may
have a certain emotional appeal and
while it does not promise to seriously
improve security it certainly diminishes
us as a society committed to run
discrimination and furnace at the very
least we should be honest with ourselves
about what ideas inform our immigration
practices and what message is sent by
them we have a long history of racism
and discrimination in our immigration
laws and policies in the United States
but we eliminated them entirely some 50
years ago are we going to allow
ourselves to be bullied into reversing
this and
turning to a system that incorporates
discrimination and injustice as a part
of its basic structure I'm afraid that
you have been drifting dangerously in
that direction in the past six months
thank you Miss my cities
thank you the core question that has
been given to us for this debate the
question of whether immigration has been
fundamentally changed by the events of
911 has been touched on in different
ways by each of us I would answer that
question along with most I think of the
speakers by saying absolutely a second
for debate has changed in very
significant ways and and a number of
those ways have already been talked
about the basic changes I see it in the
debate is that we have now been forced
to confront immigration as an issue as a
phenomenon in our society that has very
substantial security dimensions to it
and that is something that has always
been a characteristic of immigration but
it is something that we have essentially
glossed over for most of the last recent
years and I would argue have pretty much
glossed over for the last 20 30 years
but certainly for the last 10 years
fundamentally we have been treating
immigration as an economic phenomenon
and we have been seeing it through the
lens of our economy and through the lens
of the contributions that immigration
makes to our economy those contributions
are by and large very positive and are
very much a part of the story of the
incredible economic success of this
economy in in recent years but we have
been quite unwilling to look at the
complexity of immigration now we are
forced to do that with
11 because 911 shows us that there is a
very substantial security dimension to
immigration along with the issues that
surround the economy and other
characteristics of immigration so the
debate in my opinion has changed in a
fundamental way in a way that is a
paradigm shift and in a way that needs
to the demands all of the attention but
I don't think that that change in the
debate is translating into a change in
the fundamentals of immigration in the
fundamentals of our immigration policy
or of our commitment to continuing to be
a nation of immigrants now I think there
are a variety of ways of illustrating
that point let me just tick off a couple
of them if you look at the legislation
that the administration sent to the
Congress right after 911 the very first
piece of legislation that the
administration sent was basically asking
for war powers and as the Congress
passed that within a week them you know
I all of us don't even know what
happened because it was just it just
happened but the second piece of
legislation that was sent was
immigration legislation and it was the
legislation that is the source of the
issues that are being talked about here
because what it resulted in was quite a
substantial well relaxation or
broadening of the power of the
government to detain non-immigrants
however the form in which that
legislation went to the Congress was
considerably broader than what it was
that was actually enacted and I think
most of us in the field were very very
fearful that that immigration
legislation would just get
were stamped in the way that the Cold
War Powers legislation did but in fact
it's quite interesting that legislation
got slowed down to the point that the
administration had to begin to sort of
have a temper tantrum and stamp its feet
you know you've got to do this national
security etc etc but there were voices
in the Congress and there were very
substantial voices even in the
aftershock of night that immediate
aftershock of 911 that for forced the
political system to look carefully and
even though those provisions that were
passed our I would agree the misuse they
are far more contained than what it was
that the administration was looking for
and that we were in danger of having
enacted so there was right at the outset
where immigration is concerned some
pretty important red flags that went up
and that resulted in some degree over
spit over strength within the
circumstances now the real misdeeds and
the real areas of concern to me are not
what has happened in the Legislative
arena which is you know obviously the
most worrisome because once your laws
change it's very hard to change them
back it is what it is that this
administration is doing with not
necessarily even its new authorities
certainly its new authorities where
detention are concerned but with other
very very broad authorities that already
exist in the universal laws and
immigration law is a very very heavy to
a very strong tool when the government
wants to use it to its fullest extent
and that is certainly what is
that is certainly what you know what we
need to be concerned about is a site but
even proposals like a proposal that was
made by senator Feinstein where foreign
students were concerned to create to
establish a totem oratory simply stop
bringing foreign students into the
country we've got to get a hold of this
thing she got pushed back immediately
and that lasted for about a week and and
it was very very clear that the the
interests of broad sectors of the
society in maintaining the fundamentals
of our immigration system and the
fundamentals of a generous immigration
policy in terms of levels of immigration
was not going to be a pendant after
after nine eleven basic Maryland so
instead the focus has shifted to what I
think of as a whole set of
administrative issues the some of them
have been referred to but they are
basically the issues of how what about
our data systems what can we and should
we be doing to track people more
effectively why aren't we getting
cooperation the government getting a
kind of cooperation from Airlines from
the higher education establishment from
all kinds of elements of society that
need to work together more effectively
what about the funding for these things
how come our visa system missed being
able to identify people like this how
does intelligence information flow
within the government how is it shared
how is it not shared what needs to be
changed to do that these are all very
important issues and they are all things
that need to be addressed and they
should not have broken down many of them
to the extent that was revealed in 911
after that but they are how do you run
things how do you manage things they are
not questioning and shifting the basic
fundamentals as I say of our immigration
system today and its place in in our
society and I think that along with that
has come an overall public reaction that
I would not have expected I think that
it overall in the course of our history
when there have been spectacular
occurrences such as what happened on 911
those of us who have been in this field
expected a huge immigration backlash and
expected there to be a real
across-the-board public response against
immigration and it did not happen now
some of my panelists will have disagreed
on this point but I would argue that it
did not happen that essentially there
are certainly our problems there are
issues of discrimination that are
serious issues and those are they are
unacceptable and they need that needs to
change but that is different from an
immigration backlash so I think that I
associate myself with those who have
said that we have not seen an
immigration backlash and I think that
that actually is quite a responsible and
a sophisticated answer a thing to have
seen on the part of the public now I
think there are some very interesting
and important reasons that explain that
and I would divide those reasons into
two categories the politics of
immigration today and issues of the
demographics and how immigration fits
and works for us as a society today
where the politics are concerned you
have right now in the presidency
the part of the Republican Party that
has been traditionally very pragmatic
and a positive toward immigration the
bush part of the Republican Party
represents business interests represents
those parts of the economy that thrive
from immigration that understand the
contributions that immigration makes as
compared to the conservative culturally
conservative part of the Republican
Party which is much more which was
represented by Governor Wilson in
California in the mid 1990s with
Proposition 187 and campaigning an
anti-immigrant platform etc that was
immigration backlash we had immigration
backlash in this country 1993-94 95
culminating in legislation in 1996 which
is as harsh where immigration is
concerned as and and in in many ways
much more problematic than this recent
act it seems to me that was passed right
after 911 but that part of the
Republican Party was discredited it was
discredited after that period in
California and it has not been able to
come back to the fore although you
certainly hear the voice
pat buchanan is one of those voices etc
but fundamentally you have in this
administration the pragmatic wing of the
party and you have with that a
democratic party that is made up of most
major constituencies that are either
heavily immigration immigrant oriented
or very positive about immigration even
including in recent years the labor
movement which has traditionally been
very wary of immigration and has come to
a strong supporter of immigration so
that the real debate politically that's
going on in this country about
immigration yes no is a debate within
the Republican Party it's not a debate I
would arguable Republicans and Democrats
it's it's a struggle for the hearts and
minds of what the Republican Party
believes about this and it just so
happens that with Bush being you know as
I say of the pragmatic wing that tone
was set and the administration did not
take out after immigration writ large
more fundamentally of course that is a
reflection of where we are
demographically and you've heard some of
the numbers on that we are a nation of
immigrants as much as I ever have been
in our history we have just come through
a decade the 1990s that constitutes the
largest single decade of immigration in
our history more than 10 million people
came here in the 1990s it is not the
largest percentage of our population
we're second as compared to the during
the centuries of the 1900s to the 20th
century but the largest in overall
numbers that is a lot of people we have
become and are continuing to become a
very very diverse country more diverse
than we have ever been in our history
the first stake now California that has
been the strongest state of receiving
immigrants is as of the two thousand
census
made up of a majority of what we think
of as menorahs you can't really call it
nor does any more what is the majority
but the point is that whites in
California are now in the minority of
the population that will become the
pattern quite quickly probably by 2005
certainly by 2010 in at least Texas and
Florida probably in New York and then
probably Illinois a new jersey to follow
that is already the pattern in 50 of the
100 largest cities urban areas in this
nation so we are transforming ourselves
as we speak and that is only likely to
continue it is likely to continue
because of globalization globalization
has its negatives but globalization has
many many positive effects not only for
this country but for other countries
certainly for this country but because
of globalization and interconnections
among marketplaces and economies around
the world the movement of people and the
necessity and virtues of freer and freer
flows are tied together so that um
globalization along with what our needs
as a country are going to be in the
future will be the powerful engines of
continuing immigration we are an aging
society without innovation we are
society that will have strong continuing
labor market needs for immigrants in
order to remain
economically competitive and there is no
reason to believe at least for what we
know at this point that any of those
trends that any of those fundamental
directions will change in our lifetimes
so as I see it what is really happening
is that there is a very very intense
struggle going on in our politics in our
public debate in our own minds in our
thinking about how to reconcile
immigration as a historic and economic
function of this society with
immigration as a security concern now at
coltons full part of that mix and of
that formula now I am not terribly
reassured by some of the people that are
in government at the present time who we
have entrusted to help reconcile that
tension but that is not to say that the
definition of what it is that we're
dealing with is wrong and it is to say
that strong voices and strong debate and
seriously trying to work through the
real intellectual as well as practical
problem solving that's required to find
new formulas it is obviously extremely
important there is no question that we
have to find better ways to manage some
of the practical issues we do need to
know more about who is here we do need
to force ourselves to have ways for
people to comply with the terms of their
visas and not have such a lazy fair
approach to when people come and go
we've got to do a much more aggressive
job of building partnerships between
government and other institutions in the
society that have beneficiaries of
immigration and then have to help and be
in gay
each in regulating immigration and we do
have to face up in the longer term to
the problem of undocumented immigration
because we have a very large
undocumented population in this country
and if we need them for our labor
markets then we should confront that and
find ways of regularizing those flows
and bringing people above ground so that
we don't continue in this hypocrisy of
saying well we know you're here but
we're not going to do anything about it
if only because a more security
conscious time and needs will dictate
that we know better who it is that's
here and what the circumstances are
bring them here so in order to sum up I
would say absolutely the debate has
changed but I would also say that the
fundamentals of immigration have not
changed that the underlying reality and
the future for immigration to this
country continue to be driven by the
economy they continue to be driven by
our history and by our identity and that
we will continue to see immigration as a
value valuable element of our nation
thanks very much to all I distinguished
speakers now within the floor to
questions can I ask you if you have
questions to come up to the two mics
either i'll i'm also to give your name
say who you're addressing a question to
try it possible to be Greek so we can
get as many questions as possible he
said hi my name is David Phillips I'm a
student here at the j-school my
questions for mr. Meisner the debate
seems to get tricky because the United
States of America is actually two
countries it's America which is the
country Wow okay I think that it's a
tricky debate to decide what to do with
immigration because the United States of
America is actually two countries we
have America which is a country of ideas
democracy freedom things that we can
extend to everybody infinitely and then
we have the United States which is
finite which has finite resources how do
we make a policy that tries to do
justice to bug we can't let everyone who
is basically well I don't think anybody
would argue for letting everybody in and
and we do have policies and we do have
rules the issue is how do you enforce
those rules in in ways that makes
certain limits which are only real I
mean which which realistically have to
have to be the case make those limits
actually work properly and and and we
have as we see out of 9 11 not done a
good job with regulating and having
discipline in the rules that do exist
now it is not easy because of because
there are pressures many more people
want to come then we are prepared to
have or be able to have even with this
being a very generous country and a
generous and
mission policy but that is the nature of
an unequal world and you know the really
long term answer here is frankly the
answer that that that goes with the
pressures to migrate I mean the
long-term answer is that we've got to
pay a great deal more attention to
equity around the world because we
cannot solve the world's problems of
poverty and persecution through our
immigration policy that has to be solved
in many different ways we do immigration
because it meets our national interests
but not because it can fix everything
that is wrong everywhere else in the
world that takes lots of other kinds of
solutions yeah I thought your question
was very interesting because you
mentioned one by one bipolar
relationship between ideals and and
finite resources these two ideas in
conflict and I think the whole
immigration debate is filled with those
things the I NSA itself on the one hand
it so I provides services immigrants on
the other cracks out and immigrants
society at large on the one hand
somewhat cheap labor want labor that
dough will do jobs that nobody else will
do on the other hand there's a fear that
too many immigrants will drive wages
down on the one hand you want I to
reunify families you want to have my
group I want to bring together more
people like you which means bringing
more people from other places on the
other hand you have the fear of the
other so there are all sorts of I do all
please going on here in conflict with
one another in that in this debate yes
I'd like to touch on on on the question
of the immigration as related to
security I just want to point out that
the criminal drove committed the attack
on sep tember 11 Marlon was an immigrant
although the debate now is defined as
immigration versus security which is
fine the other is that it is not exactly
true that nothing happened
institutionally to impact in the
from Arab and Islamic countries because
it is not the general question of
immigration that's that debate it is the
particulars of it and in this particular
instance it is the immigrants from Arab
and Muslim countries today this very day
we've learned that the lottery
immigration the numbers of people who
have one is down by some fourteen
percent two thousand people list and all
these two thousand are from Maryland
asunder countries so there is a
disproportionate impact a selective
impact even such a thing as the as the
random body on this particular group I
mean we cannot pretend that the problem
doesn't exist as it applies to this one
particular segment and we have to face
up to what it means I don't means
globally and what it means for us as a
society no maricon I think the two
thousand census was a wake-up call to
the dark forces in this country you
don't want more immigrants in the
country I think the water issue numbers
of immigrants during the past ten years
that ms miser pointed out we're
staggering to certain elements in
society I think September 11th is a
catalyst for that movement I think the
Pat Buchanan book is going to basically
set the tone for the future debate and
as soon as the Republican Party in the
administration finishes schmoozing with
the somatic boat and gets what they
think they can get out of that they're
going to type down the screws because it
is a country of finite resources the
young man is correct about that we no
longer have an expanding western border
we don't longer have expanding and so we
say endless resources and we can exploit
insight to now in foreign countries
rather than bring people here to a lot
of them opportunities to contribute
industry etc and I think the country is
looking at itself and saying it's our
last gasp of quote mainstream close
America to possibly preserve itself
before the next census so no I think
September load was a catalyst for a lot
of these thoughts being implemented into
action now hi my name is James from
student heads off I've just got two
quick questions first one is we've
looked at the question so far from a
very marrow centric view point like
whatever America does controls what
happens with immigration which is is
probably true but I just like to put it
out there like is do you think there's
ever a chance that you know stories
filter back about detentions or whatever
that people would want to stop coming to
America is that ever going to be a
danger is that just such as more fat to
that it doesn't matter and the second
thing is to miss this Schlesinger ms
moistener just don't you think that it's
kind of being complacent a little
complacent possibly talking about you
know we're in this historical trend and
immigrations going up because that's
what happened in the you know the early
1900s and and it stopped you know people
stopped it and so just to say that
because it's such a huge thing I don't
know the exact factors but it could
figure sorry but it's comparable levels
and percentages then and now so you know
how's it been pointing out there are
these friends saying we you know we need
to crack down on immigration and our
densities being threatened and so on and
so my point is don't you think it is
wrong to be complacent about that it's
happened before and it could happen
again well I think you're absolutely
right that you have to look to
historical trends what I would look at
also which i think is very applicable to
the question for talk about tonight is
the internment of Japanese so during
World War Two a horrible incident in the
US history but very very similar so you
have a backlash against a particular
ethnic group you have people you had me
say Santa who third generation Japanese
Americans
even been to Japan for the speak
Japanese they were interned because of
their racial characteristics so you have
a backlash against a particular group
but that also happened on the eve of the
great immigration wave that we've had
over over the last 40 years so I think
you can have a particular prejudice you
can have a particular act of
discrimination against a group in it
without it affecting the actual treads
employ of immigration I'm sure you do
not imply that the pain of that one
particular group is is to be endured for
the public good I don't know except I'm
simply discussing a historical fat no
not that qualifier is good that very
different but I think the ax men point
out a career there have been movements
that have restricted draconian
restrictions on immigration to different
pairs of the country which I haven't
researched in other members of the panel
may have more information about so I
don't see any reason why they can't
occur again and senator Feinstein I
point out the Democrat she was going to
basically stop all student visas for a
period of time what happened there was I
think one percent of campus populations
cost a country of foreign students but
they take ten percent of the fee so she
had an economic court schools all came
for words that hey wait a minute we
can't lose ten percent of our student
fees so let's not go there but I think
that's really the issue i mean the issue
is in my view that barring something
unforeseen and that something you know
certainly could happen but but given
what we know now the reasons that are
sustaining the the reasons in our
society and the institutions in our
society
that are sustaining high levels of
immigration our continue to be committed
to that and have a very very strong
stake in continuing it so you know of
course things can always change I mean
and and I and I'm not sure that the word
is necessarily complacency I mean the
reason that that the immigration came to
such a trickle in nineteen at you know
in the 1920s was the result of the first
world war followed by depression and uh
and so the Congress legislated very very
severe restrictions the Congress could
do that again but what what what oh
Charles Liberace lace is driven to the
whatever you know they all kinds of all
kinds of factors but what I but i don't
see that anybody can point to strong
evidence where those kinds of impulses
would come from today it certainly
events could take us there but I don't I
haven't I have I i would have a hard
time putting my finger on them Anna and
something as astonishing and horrible is
911 she's not at least at this point to
have done that wholesale could help
guide your finger is just writing
something's been bothering me is is that
there was a increase in number of work
visas through the republican party etc a
year or two ago to allow skilled people
to come in computer skills thing we
things we lack because none enough to
you students out there i guess you're
taking engineering and computer science
courses and we have to track these
people from abroad but now since
September 11th there is ken and movement
to restrict from not secret or top
secret data banks and computer and
science operations but even classify
your senses sensitive information like
credit
backgrounds even hotel and airline
reservation information in other words
restricting immigrants from those sorts
of jobs that they were recruited to
perform in the first instance and
probably the initial restrictions would
be towards Arabs and Muslims from Middle
East countries because their suspect
right now but if they're just looming
and national security to restrict
foreigners from that sort of information
will not that not on chat be one of the
impetus emphasis towards this
restriction on immigration generally
because we won't need those people
anymore because we don't let them work
here to do that sort of work anyway can
I just comment from the chair also as a
question is that's about the
international perspective from some of
the experience that's been happening
recently in Europe we're on Ana base
where there has been a parallel and
quite strong debate on immigration and
asylum policy and restriction just as in
the United States the economic boom
grows in Europe in the postwar years was
driven partly by immigration Europe as a
whole time SEPs almost as many immigrant
says what my friend says the u.s.
internationally but there's both an
economic debate and our security debate
that parallels debate we're having here
in some countries particularly Germany
that debate is becoming of quite serious
political significance given the German
election that's coming up in this
becoming in some ways ironically a more
polarizing issue in Europe that it has
been or probably is now politically the
US where there's actually are is a
political ad or political parties are
now dividing quite significantly on
immigration in a way that they weren't
so we years ago and I should also
there's also a husband very of similar
he'll bail civil rights implications of
legislation that would lead to
restrictions on right under tensions and
in fact I think broadly Europe was more
reluctant to pass these laws than we
were all though
countries have made similar changes
partly at the request of the u.s. take
my name is Sara Schaefer I'm the
journalism student and I'd like to play
devil's advocate if I may I address my
question to mr. Hamada mr. Sally you
have justifiably so expressed a lot of
criticism for the tactics used by the US
government in the I ns2 to look at
immigrants in the wake of the sep tember
11th attacks but it seems as though no
matter what the agencies would do to
tighten security there would be some
groups crying foul and given the fact
that people involved in the September 11
attacks were University students and
some were here on I think overstate are
questionable pieces or visiting me says
what what would you suggest as a
moderate way to to take security into
consideration without without violating
on what you see is violating human and
civil rights yes so first off I want to
repeat that none of we said they
involved with that that's what we're
actually immigrants so that is an
important thing to know the
consideration that the immigrants
somehow have to be singled out because
they share the same background is
entirely much too wide and I come from a
discipline that is medicine where the
primary principle from Hippocratic oath
days which is pretty much no no not
sharing but many do no harm what what
what we have to do is in our and our
emotional reaction to the disaster that
struck the country is that just lets do
something and then you know maybe we can
isolate all these people and put them
somewhere on a boat and send them to the
moon or something that is not doable
what that does exactly and if i may be
allowed just some kind of anything
complexes its to play into the hands who
have of those who have committed the
crime in the first place to pick these
huge masses of people on religious and
and culture and civilizational course of
conflict so if we react in kind to what
they have tried to impose on us by by
isolating addict and Muslims in India in
the United States and in the West in
general then that would precisely
achieve their purpose and would make the
whole world isn't a less attractive
place to live so this is at the core of
what how we should be reacting to this
we should in fact deal with the problems
that have generated those crimes and
with the circumstances that have
generated of stunts I do want to comment
the Commissioner on a question of you
know equity in general in the world and
and I also want to say that it has been
a failure of intelligence a failure of
policy and really a failure of
comprehension and we have to deal with
souls or all of these issues as we deal
with this well your concern is more
simply expressed and I'm not being
pejorative it's like you know a bunch of
Arab Muslims attack this isn't a good
idea to call I'm grab ever ever Mazel we
can get a whole just in case they want
to attack us proof is in the pudding
well I mean that's essentially what you
said ever we do in other words and what
they have done is it can incarcerate it
over
augmented Arab Muslim man who fits the
age criterias possible potential sleeper
cell members and/or potential terrorists
to see if they could possibly deter
future acts of terrorism first of all
the proof is of all those people that
incarcerated not a one was found to be
guilty of any connection to September
11th or any membership in al-qaeda the
one person who one person who's been
charged the kairos Zechariah salary was
incarcerated on august 15 a month before
almost a month of a force of timber 11th
so of the dragnet and all the resources
spent in casting the dragnet and
imprisoning these men they've come up
with zip because there was nothing there
also if you're going to think and act
ethnically then people like John Walker
John Reed you're going to slip through
the net because the award Arabs then
they can not make it very easy not
appear to be Muslims or fanatic
fanatical in their views the best and
the most reasonable approach to avoid
continuing man's and ours and internment
of 1942 ad nauseam the future is to take
a close look at your intelligent from
inch intelligence information properly
look at the bad people that you've
identified the 19 hijackers that worked
at a fight look where they've been
hamburg germany malaysia Tlakula spoken
with and look who then met with and find
the co-conspirators just like you would
a drug dealer that's how you protect
America you don't protect America with a
wide ethnic dragnet because this country
spent two hundred and fourteen years
trying to teach people to get along with
each other and when you start this
country down the road is where our
speakers are getting pointed out
thinking ethnically again racially again
singling out an ethnic religious
for special treatment majority treatment
than we destroy what we want September
10th were less of the country in
September 12 so that's my responsibility
to pontificate my name is Professor
Lehman school of business Hofstra
University it was very elegant
nonetheless thank you very much junkie
on thank you to all the speaker's here
it is a very difficult issue um I wanted
to return I thought it was a very
interesting question the first question
that we have a bifurcated society one in
which we have e ideals and second in
which we have limited resources I hate
to be overly idealistic but we don't
really have necessarily limited
resources the National Research Council
did a very large study in the late 1900s
just about the issue that you brought
out is immigration good economically
culturally or is it bad and they crunch
through all those numbers and many of
the numbers were it's good it's a good
thing and there's a lot of quality and
quantitative issues that we can talk
about in that but I want to return to
that unfortunately I think the need for
that study emerged out of the fact that
were a racist society and there's much
discrimination 3 911 including the 1900s
and here today in our great 21st century
there's a racial profiling and the paper
from police there's fortune 500 CEOs
saying horrible things about blacks and
jews and asians so i think we have to
really deal with the fact that
immigration cannot be can it be
bifurcated from our notions about
discrimination and
scizzum and it's very scary that Bush
administration as you've said is
suddenly going to change the rules of
the games for Mexican immigrants because
they want the Hispanic voters ah you
know that is such political maneuvering
that it frightens me rather than says
yay at least some people are getting in
so I would like you to speak to that
issue about you know I think you said it
very eloquently more so than myself
there is a lot of racism and
discrimination in pre and post 9-11
immigration policy where do we as a
community go from here to change that
let's not mix my style that thank you
well so I concur the mean the issue of
racism discrimination and Prejudice you
know is a fact of our history it's
probably a fact of every society that
that exists on earth I would argue that
we probably as a society struggle harder
with it or or or more or let's say as
our as bedeviled by it as as as any
society today but it you know one of the
questions is is it inherent human nature
and let's hope not but you know we
certainly have not solved those problems
the difficulty in the immigration arena
is that our immigration laws have a long
history our immigration laws essentially
have have had very have been part of the
institutional structure of racism if you
want if you want to be declared about it
that way in this country I mean the
first immigration laws that were
actually enacted after the
naturalization statutes the first
immigration laws we ever have our
naturalization statutes after that the
first laws that we passed targeted
ethnicities for exclusion Chinese and
Asian in the late 1880s and then
culminated in National Origins quotas
after the First World War and as I says
was said here earlier around obvi that
the Japanese internment was part of the
internal security you know machinery oh
that had something to do with
immigration and all of those not look
then we went to the ideological
exclusions that had to do with communism
and beliefs in anarchy answer our
aggression lies are replete with these
problems and only as somebody else said
within the last 50 years actually in
1965 were those provisions washed out of
the statutes and that was part of
President Kennedy's carrying the ideas
of civil rights as fully through dexter
view as possible to include changes in
the immigration laws so I view this as a
you know a perpetual struggle and what
my colleague has said hear about the
danger of putting us stepping back into
those pathways is very real and very
important given that history David Lee
yeah I agree with me finds it very much
that the history of the immigration laws
are replete with racism racism ascends
from the natural human fear of the other
but I think it's important also to keep
in mind that what is the other has
changed I think it's an amazing
statistic that now 51 percent of the
Ford one people united states
from Latin America that's not a Democrat
problem that's not a Republican issue
that is because of where we are in our
hemispheres become it's because we are
now much more a part a full heart of our
hemisphere yes there were the
anti-chinese laws but now twenty five
percent of the foreign-born are from
Asia so the what the American demography
has changed profoundly and I think that
that is a constant process it's an
evolving process and that series to
ameliorate some of the racism has been
in society it doesn't help the Arab
American problem at all because it's
such a small slice of that picture but
when you have such a huge numbers of
Hispanic Americans of Asian Americans
now that is changing attitudes well and
the water just came about because of the
1965 changes in the lava opened that
opened immigration two groups that have
been excluded well our concern of course
is to learn from history our concern is
always about the present in the future
whether what is unfolding right now is
in major form of racism in this country
and if you watch TV you would think that
the middle name of Erebus is terrorist
and that is not a coincidence that is a
built of prejudice and an instant
discrimination in everybody's mind and
it's internalized and that reflects
itself in policies in the center and we
know we know what is being proposed now
in by Ashcroft no less is another layer
of complication of the right life of a
band what's the immigrants and it is
going to be barring something unusual be
tolerated and passed because the
atmosphere of racism is so emotionally
charged and permeating in the sculpture
that it will do the damage ends and
we'll take us you know some dickies and
that is why we're here and that's why
we're talking about it now so people
actually
have a certain degree of integrity as
they discuss this question and
understand that this racism cannot be
encoded should not be included if we are
going to beat what we claim we are
whether we call ourself USA or like I
just point out that I am smarter to
learn to speak Spanish so I'm going to
try and blend in wherever I can hi my
name is Sven Pugsley I'm an undergrad
here miss Meisner I would agree that we
certainly didn't have the the wholesale
immigration backlash that we could have
had but there has been a palpable
backlash against the Arab community or
the potential error immigrant think that
including as mr. Hmoob mentioned the
additional questions that that single
out immigrants from Saudi Arabia or
other middle eastern states and then
immigrants from everywhere else it's not
something that's appropriate or do we
need a colorblind immigration policy we
serve we actually you know well we need
of course a colorblind immigration
policy this is you know what what you're
talking about and what we are pointing
to here are by and large actions on the
part of the executive branch you know
there have not really been legislative
changes that have introduced into the
law new elements of immigration
discrimination but there are practices
where the executive branch is exercising
its discretion by selectively applying
elements of a law that is a very very
that allows for enormous discretion and
it's I believe being used improperly in
many instances but that is more
changeable than wholesale sketch
changes this this item that was referred
to here for instance of the Justice
Department drafting an opinion that
would allow state and local law
enforcement officers to enforce
immigration law is a very very dangerous
trend and those are the kinds of things
that I think that that this will now
this will get enough discussion and this
is this is an authority it was put into
the law in 1996 who fought against it we
ask the Congress not to give us that
authority when we actually got the
authority we did everything possible not
to implement it and by by that i mean we
forced enormous local consultation and
outreach among police agencies in order
for them to understand what it really
meant to be implementing the immigration
law because it's a very complicated law
to to implement my prediction on this is
as mr. salia said that local police
departments after a certain flurry of
activity will refuse I mean they will
determine that is not wise for them to
exercise this authority and that is the
way these things get worked out of me
you know I I I am NOT a Pollyanna about
these sorts of things but it is only six
months since September eleventh happened
I mean we are in a period of enormous
churn as a society in trying to grope
our way toward understanding reality
where immigration is one of the central
things that we are trying to that we
have to revisit on the set of time the
would could I just have one last
question from the person over there and
then give each of the panelists a chance
to respond both to that and more
generally my name is
goldhirsch and the student at Columbia
and you guys spoke about the racial
profiling and other arrests that are
affecting arab-american community and
given the secretive nature of these
activities how do you suggest that
average Americans help to combat that I
think you have to be vocal against it I
think I think Americans African
Americans Hispanic Americans people who
have fought for their rights through the
civil rights movement of the 60s and 70s
to get where they are in this country
today guardedly but much progress have
to really be very vocal in their
opposition to those sorts of tactics
because they were victimized by those
same tactics for well over 200 years in
this country and they don't need to be
revisited on another ethnic group
because then on the balance and they
came back to roost at home again and I
think you need to be in touch with your
opinion leaders your elected
representatives at all levels not just
at the federal level the local level
also especially police departments are
going to be enforcing the immigration
laws we might not want to go there as
the first line of defense and don't be
afraid to stand up and fight it because
what's happened in my experience and
I've written an article and it's been
published in the California water
magazine I brought some reprints that
are out there and they'll run out if you
want to read about how terrorize the
arab-american community is nobody really
wants to defend suspected terrorists or
fellow traveler terrorists or people who
are Arab or Muslim dissent because they
might be terrorists in the sense that
you know their nobody wants to really
help a bad guy and I can
or bad gal but at the same time people
also don't want to speak up against
what's happening because they say well
maybe there is a sleeper cell in the
country maybe there are some super
chairs here maybe we ought to let the
government run amok in case they stumble
across some of them you really need to
be very brave near hear a vocalization
of opposition to racial profiling to
ethnically discriminating against any
group in the country for any reason
because it doesn't work in the long term
it will cause egregious harm in long
term and with respect to Arabs and
Muslims now if the United States has
become embroiled and involved in a 40
years 40 year old civil war in Colombia
and take sides and kill Clements and
effect Colombian families down there
millions of Colombians living in the
country here who could say that there
won't be terrorism generated by those
sorts of policies later you can have a
pandemic terrorist movement by various
groups with axes to grind because the
foreign policy united states have
alienated them and they're already here
in states or coming into the state so
you can't think I think what you have to
think fairness for everybody reasonable
policies let's not take this terrorism
war to be an instrument of repression
across the world today and it is even
more as a country from from ethnic
groups who already represented here who
might have an actually grind later speak
up and speak out loud we had some might
say I think that it's important to bear
in mind Zac that immigration policies
here in the United States and around the
world are based on fears and prejudices
and on economic realities I think a lot
of the things that we've talked about
tonight stem from the horrific events of
September 11th and also the confluence
of a major economic slowdown I think as
there is some distance from September
11th as the economy turns around will
some of the harsher prejudices in a
harsher I discrimination against Arab
Americans will be ameliorated and I
think that they like the longer-term
trends of immigration policy will
continue I think the answer to this and
all problems of discrimination of
prejudice is the same we all have to be
part of the civil rights movement it is
our collective and individual civil
rights that are being
and we must fight this good fight on the
political level and in the media and in
court and we all must understand that we
individually have a contribution to make
at all these levels at these three
levels and we must do it because if we
don't do it our civil rights we are now
in minority within a minority of a
monarchy we are dispensable Morris but
it is your fight and ours together and
this is the civil right off the America
or the dream of the America that our
friend was talking about that's at stake
and we should get involved it's hard to
add anything to that I I think i would
say that it sort of easily slips off our
tongues to say there were a nation of
immigrants but we are a nation of
immigrants that's how we established
ourselves and that's how we will
continue to have the incredible
comparative advantage in the world that
we do have immigration I believe is one
of the most difficult things that we do
as a society we do it very imperfectly
but we really do struggle to try to do
it and we are one of the few societies
in the world that in fact does feel that
does approach it as an affirmative
overall positive characteristic and but
it is a struggle and it is a struggle
because of the things that have been
talked about here and it probably always
will be a work in progress simply
because of the incredible emotion and
difficulty that it represents but as I
said we are today transforming ourselves
in the way that we have
formed ourselves several times in the
past those things are never pretty when
they're actually taking place you know
it's that thing about you don't ever
want to see legislation being written
it's the same as watching sausage being
made I mean it is not easy to be in the
trenches but as a society we are dealing
with a peak period of immigration in our
history we are we making ourselves and
we need to do the kinds of things that
have been said here in order to be sure
that it comes out right thank you all
very much